a new preferred is underway to avoid
more wrong way drivers on Tropicana
right over the 15. we're talking about
that diverging diamond interchange it
reopened this morning after the Nevada
Department of Transportation shut it
down again last night now they were
working to install some new signage to
help drivers because it can be a little
bit confusing and Dot spokesman Justin
Hopkins says it's been a learning curve
for drivers and for ndot
if you grew up driving in the United
States and you learned how to drive here
crossing over into a diverging diamond
is not necessarily intuitive diverging
diamond interchanges are becoming more
popular but people don't tend to drive
through them on a daily basis so uh
there is a bit of a driver education
piece a bit of a catch-up that needs to
happen
ndot also rotating those green arrows on
the diverging diamond traffic signals to
point it in the direction that drivers
should go Hopkins also telling us there
could be more closures related to all
this coming up